Japan's nuclear nightmare is never
ending it's been eight months since a
catastrophic earthquake and series of
tsunamis crippled the Fukushima nuclear
plant the rubble and splintered
buildings remain and so does the anxiety
over japan's dependence on nuclear power
the area around the plant is still
contaminated tens of thousands of
residents have been unable to return
home but for the first time since the
disaster a group of journalists has been
allowed inside the complex after months
of criticism over its response to the
crisis the Japanese government says the
plant will be in cold shutdown by the
end of the year but that won't be the
end of it thousands of workers are still
on site some have been there since it
first went into meltdown some lost their
homes and families to the tsunami no
workers have died from radiation
exposure but in Japan many view them as
heroes sacrificing their own health for
the nation some believe allowing
journalist teen was an unnecessary risk
the minister himself who accompany these
journalists has said during that visit
that at Chernobyl 25 years later they
still have radiation there they still
cannot occupy the area and he said so I
understand to those journalists pointing
towards Fukushima that they still don't
know where the nuclear fuel is it's
melted down and run into the system they
can't account for but this is all part
of a concerted effort by the Japanese
government to allay the public's anger
over the way it's handled the nuclear
disaster last month an official drank
this glass of water on live television
it came from the fukushima reactor
buildings he said it was decontaminated
and safe to drink it was an eye-catching
stunt but probably not enough to
reassure a fearful Japanese public about
living with nuclear power Holly Williams
thy news Beijing